smoke billows from the rubble as
Rescuers continue to search for
survivors in the Ukrainian city of
danipro emergency teams had worked
through the night in the cold and dark
sifting through the debris of an
apartment block that was destroyed by a
Russian missile some people were pulled
out alive
some were badly injured among the dead
was a 15 year old girl
emergency workers tried to console one
woman who'd lost her son
what have you done to my son you cowards
I'll curse you forever let the whole
world curse you
the missile strike was part of a wave of
Russian attacks across Ukraine on
Saturday that officials said targeted
power infrastructure in a village near
Kiev one missile landed near this man's
house
elsewhere in the capital people took
shelter after a series of explosions
while cities including harciv and leviv
were plunged Into Darkness
it's terrible what happened in nipro I
hope there aren't any more victims it's
a shame that the whole world is watching
this and that no one can stop this
horror they could of course but they
don't want to Ukraine's military says it
shot down more than 20 of over 30
Russian missiles that were launched in
the biggest wave of attacks on the
country since the New Year
Ukraine's president said the only way to
stop what he called Russian terrorism
was for the West to send more weapons
the weapons that our partners have in
their warehouses are the ones our
Warriors are waiting for if time runs
out we cannot stop the terrorists who
are methodically killing our people with
missiles
Britain says it will send some of its
Challenger two tanks to Kiev zelenski
hopes that will persuade other Western
powers to do the same and help Ukraine
better defend itself against more
attacks like this
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Kiev